[Música]
los 20 acusados por los atentados
terroristas de parís en 2015 fueron
condenados por mayor sentencia se la
llevó sala a abdeslam el único
sobreviviente de la unidad yihadista y
que pagará cadena perpetua en los
ataques mataron a 130 personas
en mexico le dispararon y asesinaron al
periodista antonio de la cruz en el
ataque hirieron a su hija es el
reportero número 12 a quien nadan en el
país en lo que va del año la fiscalía
general abrió una investigación
que endurezca las medidas migratorias es
la petición que hace el gobierno
republicano de texas al presidente de
eeuu joe biden el pronunciamiento llega
dos días después de que encontraron los
cuerpos de 53 migrantes en un camión 13
personas permanecen en un estado
delicado de salud
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos y comenzamos en francia
después de 10 meses de audiencias la
justicia condenó a los 20 acusados
dentro del proceso por los ataques
terroristas de parís en 2015 los
atentados fueron los más mortíferos en
esa nación desde la segunda guerra
mundial pues en ellos 130 personas
perdieron la vida entonces los
responsables pagarán cadena perpetua una
condena que en francia sólo se había
impuesto a cuatro personas luís muñoz
tiene todos los detalles
casi siete años después justicia el
tribunal especial de parís condenó a
sala a abdeslam la cadena perpetua es la
quinta sentencia máxima en la historia
de francia y fue para el único
perpetrador superviviente de los
atentados del 13 de noviembre en parís y
sant dennis murieron 130 personas en la
mayor matanza en francia desde la
segunda guerra mundial del resto de
acusados otros 19 fueron reconocidos
culpables de todos sus cargos menos uno
que solo fue condenado por el delito de
concierto para delinquir
tenemos la sensación después del
veredicto de que estamos pasando página
desesperadas no son excesivas se adaptan
tanto a los hechos
para las víctimas esta sentencia también
supone el fin de una etapa después de
años esperando este momento podrán
respirar
pero antes de pensar en las secuelas ya
la digerir pero hemos terminado un
primer ciclo y ahora hay que pensar en
el siguiente todavía espero poder
conjugar la palabra víctima del pasado
pero no estoy satisfecho con la
sentencia y creo igual que mucha gente
que es justa no hay que exagerar no hay
que pedir más pero yo creo que todo lo
he hecho ha sido de acuerdo con la ley y
eso es buena y todo lo que espero que
esté bien
el juicio ha durado nueve meses ahora
los acusados podrán apelar a una
sentencia escrita de 120 páginas que
recibirán el jueves ahora hablemos de
noticias en américa matando al
periodista mexicano antonio de la cruz
el reportero número 12 que asesinan en
lo que va del año en ese país según la
sociedad interamericana de prensa a él
le dispararon cuando salía de su casa en
ciudad victoria en el noreste mexicano e
hirieron a su hija de la cruz trabajaba
en expreso victoria
previamente hablamos con el director
editorial del medio miguel domínguez
quien nos explicó si sirve o no que sea
la fiscalía general y no el estado la
que investigue el crimen
antonio la cruz era un periodista muy
experimentado con más de vida empezamos
a trabajar en este periódico en esa
larga trayectoria te imaginarás que pues
cubrió todas las temáticas periodísticas
posibles
recientemente se especializó mucho en
temas comunitarios en temas de medio
ambiente en temas del campo esas eran
las fuentes que cubría formalmente para
nuestro medio pero aparte el de manera
independiente era un usuario muy activo
de las redes sociales donde bueno él
cubría y reportaba todo tipo de
informaciones de diferentes áreas
seguridad política en fin ese era
antonio legos bueno nosotros
esperaríamos que funcione en teoría es
una fiscal y si es cálida que está
especializada en los delitos contra la
libertad de expresión
desafortunadamente también hay que decir
y ustedes pueden saber méxico atraviesa
por una crisis grave en términos de
violencia contra el periodismo en la que
la impunidad desafortunadamente sí es
una constante aquí mismo en tamaulipas
ha habido muchos asesinatos
de compañeros que han quedado impunes
nuestra exigencia es muy clara que sea
la fiscalía estatal o la fiscalía
federal pero que este crimen se
esclarezca que se dé con los
responsables y que se les castigue y en
nicaragua la asamblea nacional canceló
las personalidades jurídicas de otras
101 ongs con lo que se elevan a 758 la
orden las organizaciones ilegalizadas en
el país los parlamentarios oficialistas
consideraron que las entidades no
cumplen con todos los requisitos de la
ley de lavado de activos pero la
oposición tilda las acciones como una
persecución pues las ilegalizaciones han
sido solicitadas por el gobierno de
daniel ortega especialmente después de
las protestas antigubernamentales de
y el gobierno del estado de texas en
eeuu le pidió al presidente joe biden
que endurezca las medidas migratorias y
que retomen las políticas que en su
momento fueron impuestas durante la
administración del ex presidente de
donald trump la petición del gobernador
republicano llega después de que en su
estado encontraran un camión abandonado
dentro había 53 personas muertas de las
cuales 27 eran mexicanas 13 migrantes
más luchan en este momento por su vida
mientras que muchas familias buscan
noticias de sus parientes la historia la
tiene natalia plazas
la familia de javier flórez pide ayuda
para encontrarlo él podría ser uno de
los migrantes mexicanos que viajaban en
el camión de contrabando en cuyo
interior fallecieron decenas de personas
en busca de mejor vida como les vuelvo a
repetir esto que nos que nos ayuden por
localizarlo pues ya dijeron lo que nos
toca flores y su primo josé luís vázquez
habían partido rumbo a eeuu vázquez es
uno de los sobrevivientes se encuentra
en un hospital de texas tras sufrir
deshidratación severa pero aún no hay
constancia del paradero de javier ni si
realmente iba en el camión según el
gobierno mexicano al menos 27 de los
fallecidos son mexicanos y los
sobrevivientes están en situación
crítica en general el personal médico de
los hospitales
insisto en general ha indicado que los
heridos están en estado crítico con
fallas neurológicas renales y hepáticas
y con hemorragias internas en medio de
este contexto el gobernador de texas
pidió al presidente joe biden retornar a
la estricta política migratoria de
donald trump incluyendo la construcción
del polémico muro fronterizo
todo lo que hemos hecho hasta ahora no
habría sido necesario si el presidente
de baidu no hubiera mantenido el plan de
seguridad fronteriza que había
implementado el ex presidente de manchón
las políticas migratorias de tron fueron
criticadas por no atacar los problemas
de raíz de la migración como la pobreza
o la violencia en los países de origen
mientras la actual administración
enfrenta una mayor presión por la
gestión de la frontera redoblada de cara
a las elecciones de medio término de
noviembre
bardem ha prometido combatir en bandas
de tráfico de personas y su gobierno
busca estrategias regionales para frenar
los flujos migratorios
en eeuu uno de los nueve jueces de la
corte suprema de justicia se jubilará
oficialmente este jueves se trata del
liberal stephen breyer quien sirvió a la
corte desde 1994 sin embargo su retiro
no cambia la tendencia política del
máximo órgano judicial pues en su
reemplazo llega la jueza que tangi brawn
jackson designada por el presidente
demócrata joe biden así se mantienen los
seis jueces conservadores y los tres
progresistas
nuevo estado de excepción en ecuador el
presidente guillermo lasso decretó la
medida para cuatro provincias imbabura a
súa y sucumbíos y orellana durante 30
días en esas regiones se restringen los
derechos a la libertad de asociación y
de reunión y habrá un toque de queda
nocturno es la tercera vez que el
presidente decreta excepción desde que
comenzaron las protestas lideradas por
los indígenas hace tan solo cuatro días
había levantado la medida y ahora la
impuso de nuevo
esta decisión tiene el objetivo de
recuperar el orden público controlar
situaciones de violencia manifiesta
proteger áreas reservadas asegurar la
provisión de medicamentos gases
medicinales oxígeno para hospitales y
clínicas combustibles y alimentos y la
integridad de la ciudadanía
el cantante de estadounidense kelly fue
sentenciado a 30 años de prisión por
extorsión y delitos sexuales el artista
ya había sido declarado culpable por
nueve cargos penales incluidos el de
transportar a personas a través de las
fronteras estatales para la prostitución
varias mujeres le contaron al juez que
martelly prometió guiar las y ayudarlas
a alcanzar el estrellato pero luego
según sus relatos la sometía a tratos
sexuales degradantes e incluso al daño
físico el cantante es uno de los
personajes más conocidos que han sido
condenados durante el movimiento ni tú
kelly apelar a la sentencia
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
los invitamos a que sigan conectados con
nuestra programación ya que consulten
más actualidad internacional en france24
punto com nos vemos
[Música]